bonjour et bienvenue ici a les seins ou
je vais vous parler de jouer la galette
et nicolas martin et pourquoi dans la
série achetée avec des bâtons mieux il
faut vraiment qu'on en parle
[Musique]
je vais commencer par julia grève parce
que je suis un fan absolu de jeu égal f
de la manière dont elle réfléchit et
surtout de la manière dont elles débat
est également à la une superbe chaîne
youtube qui s'appelle diaghilev est
vraiment en fait cette série tant mieux
c'est pas mal juste des traductions des
vidéos de suez edf qui a déjà fait tout
le travail
j'ai envie de dire il y aura des trucs
que je voudrais rajouter mais vraiment
ce que fait joseph est vraiment
fantastique et je recommande très
vivement
toutes ces vidéos mais ce que je trouve
encore plus fabuleux avec jacquet est
faux de là que c'est super de réflexion
sur notamment comment mieux débattre
c'est qu'elle met tout ça en pratique
notamment sur son merveilleux podcast
quand il pleut des cordes temps sur ce
merveilleux podcast rationner speaking
ou à la particularité d'interviewer des
gens qui sont bien plus exclure qu'elle
ait du coup à l'heure en situation de
débats ouais je cherche parfois elle et
m voilà m et titiller à les mettre en
difficulté mais à chaque fois elle fait
ça avec beaucoup de bienveillance à
liart il est très bien et surtout en
reconnaissant entièrement le fait que l
es très ignorante et beaucoup plus
ignorante que les experts sur les
différents sujets qu'elle aborde c'est
une mer de face on veut voir comment est
ce qu'on peut avoir des discussions très
très très très bonne avec des gens qui
sont très supérieurs à nous en tout cas
en terme d' expertise et je dois bien
dire qu'au début en fait j'écoute est
rassuré speaking plus pour les
intervenants que pour les questions de
juliette et jean ex intervenants sont
des experts des domaines pendant c'est
ce qu'il fait de mieux mais bien souvent
fait au fur et à mesure des podcasts je
me suis mis à davantage écoutés jules
haag alex notamment la perspicacité des
questions je me pose toujours la
question mais quelle est la question que
j'ai la gueule va pouvoir poser pour que
ce soit aussi intéressant que possible
et je trouve que son choix des questions
une parfois même juste des réflexions
c'est pas juste des questions
donc c'est vraiment une situation de
débat et je trouve que joseph m'étonne à
chaque fois très régulièrement par la
perspicacité de ces questions me dit ah
ça c'est un truc qui est bien mieux que
ce que j'aurais pu avoir dit si j'étais
à la place
et idem pour nicolas martin il arrive
souvent que lors de ses émissions
je le trouve plus intéressant et de
manière plus intelligente que les
experts qui l'interviewent c'est peu
dire vu la qualité des experts qui
l'interviewent mais c'est vrai que je
prête de plus en plus d'importance
la tension va dire aux interviews war
plutôt que vous interview oui et il ya
quelque chose de vraiment fascinant dans
la qualité des questions de l'auditoire
d'arts plastiques hall martin j'ai eu la
chance de le voir en action puisqu'il
avait invité une fois une de ses
émissions et il est vraiment
impressionnant et assez ébahi par par
l'aisance avec laquelle il introduit ces
différents sujets ces différentes
questions c'est vraiment vraiment
quelque chose de remarquable je vous
invite vraiment à prêter attention à
nicole martin a pris deux fois que vous
écouterez la méthode scientifique est
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles je
trouve vu un gars l'a fait nicolas
martin vraiment fantastique c'est que il
ya vraiment un peu de tout dans leur
façon de débattre en particulier il ya
cette façon préliminaire de mettre
vraiment tout le monde bien à l'aise au
début pour éviter un truc trop
conflictuel et où il ya vraiment cette
démarche d'essayer de faire en sorte que
les interviewés se sentent à l'aise et
puisse vraiment posé leurs arguments
prennent aux contres prendre le temps de
dire ce qu'ils ont à dire et de
clarifier ce qu'ils ont à clarifier et
si c'est pas assez clair constamment
cherché à clarifier les choses au rang
des choses vraiment vraiment clair en
tout cas dans un premier temps pour
vraiment être sûr que l'on sache de quoi
on parle et puis petit à petit ils vont
essayer de soulever les points un peu
plus compliqué un peu plus litigieux et
possiblement mettre leurs interlocuteurs
un petit peu en difficulté si d'éditer
un petit peu sans jamais que ce soit de
façon virulente pour qu'ils se sentent
tout de même à l'aise dans la discussion
et voilà vraiment ce jeu qui est
vraiment intéressant entre c'est quand
même de pousser les arguments à bout
sans jamais être dans une confrontation
trop frontal qui ferait que les
personnes se braquer que la discussion
partent en vrille
et puis généralement que ce soit nicolas
martin ou jules haag à la fil ont
vraiment cette capacité à bien parler et
à bien débattre y compris lorsqu'ils ne
sont pas du tout expert de leurs sujets
y compris lorsqu'il parle à des gens
beaucoup plus experts que
et néanmoins il arrive à dire des choses
très intelligentes et reste très
intéressante
voilà donc c'est pas les se sont pas les
seuls il y en a d'autres que j'admire
énormément cité par the sun carroll ou
encore robert wood line côté anglophone
côté francophone je trouve que absolvent
le fait également très très bien lui
aussi et je vous invite à prêter
attention à cette partie 2 comment bien
débattre et à essayer de trouver de
l'inspiration chez eux en tout cas c'est
ce que j'essaie de faire pour que moi
aussi je sois amener à mieux débattre
quand je ne suis pas expert d'un sujet
et même quand je le suis je trouve que
cette attitude de questionnement est
vraiment vraiment intéressante
une dernière chose que je trouve très
important dans la manière de débattre de
juger des faits de nicolas martin c'est
l'important ce qu'il donne aux
questionnements fait ils sont quasiment
tout le temps en train de questionner
leurs interlocuteurs avant c'est normal
il ya le format n'est sûr que ça lui
allait si vous écoutez les premiers
podcast de juin gala vous allez avec
massimo pédagogie ils sont en gros au
même niveau a priori au même niveau de
débat pas ce qui m'a pas mal frappé en
braille et coutances et vieux épisodes
c'est que j'ai eu la greffe est beaucoup
beaucoup plus dans le questionnement
depuis massimo pédagogique hull inverse
est dans la réflexion au sein qui a
réfléchi en au moment de débattre
tout ça fait que vois je trouve qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup à apprendre
de jus la galère c'est quelque chose que
moi personnellement j'aimerais avoir
beaucoup plus dans les différents débats
on a tendance à beaucoup paraît à
beaucoup donné son opinion a beaucoup a
expliqué telle ou telle chose
dans un débat en fait je pense qu'ils
auraient beaucoup plus à gagner à être
beaucoup plus dans le questionnement
lors des débats et non pas des
questionnements agressif dans le but
d'essayer de piéger l'autre dans le but
des questionnements ne doit pas être de
piéger autres ça va vraiment être de
clarifier la situation
damn et l'autre à mieux expliquer ses
positions à se cacher autant que
possible mais également à soulever des
questions si possible auquel ni
l'interlocuteur ni nous mêmes n'avons de
réponse at il juré que ce soit mis en
pratique aussi tôt que possible sur
twitter par exemple dans les
commentaires de cette affaire un petit
voile à 360° parce que le paysage est
quand même magnifique et donc dites moi
quels sont les questions que vous vous
posez
mais ta question